la medida ha sido aprobada después de
una reunión del politburó a la que
asistido el presidente chino xi jinping
la reforma legal se daba por descontada
debido a los graves problemas de
envejecimiento que sufre china pero los
expertos dudan de su eficacia que
recordad que en 2015 la derogación de la
política del hijo único no sirvió para
estimular la natalidad hoy en día no es
la ley la que brinda a los nacimientos
sino un contexto socioeconómico muy
parecido al de occidente las parejas
jóvenes rechazan las familias numerosas
argumentando las extenuantes jornadas
laborales la incertidumbre o la carestía
de vida además añade un factor chino
como ese de la extrema competitividad de
su sociedad lo que aconseja a muchas
parejas jóvenes concentrar todos sus
recursos económicos en un hijo en lugar
de dividirlos el último censo chino
corroboraba que la población está
creciendo a su nivel más bajo durante
décadas lo que anticipa
graves inminentes como la reducción de
la masa laboral o la sostenibilidad del
sistema de pensiones